es hat für große aufregung gesorgt als
sie den tramp indiana davon gesprochen
hat die nato sei obsolet gerade in
europa haben die alarmglocken geläutet
wir sollten uns wirklich genau überlegen
was es für europa bedeuten könnte wenn
die nato nicht mehr so funktionieren
würde die bisher
[Musik]
in europa haben die alarmglocken
geläutet nachdem präsident trump in
einem interview gemeint hat die nato sei
obsolet
wir sorgen sie nicht ganz unbegründet
den nato war und ist die wichtigste
sicherheitsallianz in europa und für
europa allerdings ist auch die kritik
von seiten der usa zu verstehen weil
schon präsident obama darauf hingewiesen
hat dass die europäer zu wenig in den
gemeinsamen topf einzahlen 25 prozent
von europäischer seite 75 prozent von
amerikanischer seite sieht man sich die
verteidigungsaufgaben an es noch
drastischer
die usa geben alleine 650 milliarden
jährlich für das militär aus während in
europa in etwa 300 milliarden ausgegeben
werden
wozu das führen kann haben wir bereits
2011 gesehen als einige europäische
staaten im luftkrieg gegen libyen
gestanden sind und ihnen nach wenigen
tagen nach einer woche die lenkraketen
ausgegangen sind und sie die usa gebeten
haben ihnen welche nachzuliefern
betrachtet man die entwicklung insgesamt
könnte man auf drei szenarien kommen was
diese aussage bedeuten kann
die variante 1 szenario 1 die usa machen
ernst und geben wirklich deutlich
signifikant weniger für die nato aus um
die europäer sind auch nicht bereit das
ganze aufzufangen
das wäre ein herber verlust für die
europäische sicherheit und würde auch
die position russlands gegenüber europa
massiv stärken
variante 2 wäre die usa bleiben im
bisherigen ausmaß in der nato verbunden
und geben auch annähernd wieder vor ort
die europäer allerdings sind auch bereit
mehr dafür zu tun was natürlich die
gesamte position der transatlantischen
allianz aber auch der europäischen
staaten massiv verbessern würde
eine dritte option könnte sein dass die
usa nicht mehr so viel ausgeben die
bücher sich auch ein bisschen
zurückziehen aus der nato aber die
europäer zu einem schulterschluss bereit
sind und hier in diesem schulterschluss
einfach mehr aufbringen mehr gemeinsam
machen mehr für die europäische
sicherheit bringen wollen
das könnte unter dem strich die
geburtsstunde einer tatsächlichen
europäischen gemeinsamen sicherheits und
verteidigungspolitik sein
wir wissen nicht welche varianten davon
kommen die nato ist sicher nicht wo
zuletzt davon kann man ausgehen
wie sich allerdings alle diese staaten
treffen werden wer macht was wir jetzt
bereit was zu tun
da für die zukunft zeigen abonnieren sie
diesen kanal
ich biete sicherheitspolitik kompakt